hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
in the very end of book nine of his
meditations Marcus Aurelius in chapter
42 is going to lay out for us a number
of really important considerations that
we shouldn't lose sight of and if we
keep these in mind we will be able to
avoid falling into the Trap of getting
upset with all sorts of people in the
world by not having such unrealistic
expectations about how they are and how
the world is so he begins by saying when
you run up against when you encounter
someone else's
shamelessness on ice contia right which
means like doing things without caring
whether they're right or wrong or
whether they hurt other people not
feeling bad about it right so there are
people who characteristically behave
that way it's not just screwing up a
little bit it's screwing up in being a
human being so when you encounter this
ask yourself something if you start
getting upset
is it really possible for there not to
be shamelessness in the world is how
it's literally said in the Greek here's
another translation is a world without
shamelessness possible and you know we
could pause on that for a moment and say
well yeah because anything that we can
think of is possible so yeah sure we
could have this Utopia in which
shamelessness doesn't occur I'm just
taking you know a few tweaks to this
universe and Marcus would stop you there
and say okay think this through how is
that actually going to be the case given
the way the world is given the kind of
human beings that we're working with
given the many different ways we go
astray no if you're being realistic
about possibilities no it's it's not
possible you're never going to have a
world without shamelessness
same thing for other character flaws
being vicious now the translation here
of vicious could also it's sometimes
translated roguish right and we often
view that as kind of like oh somebody's
just doing a few bad things but
literally it means like the kind of
person who will stoop to anything who
will do anything pan urugos they will
set their hands to just about any task
whether it's robbing old ladies of their
purses on the street or pushing people
onto train tracks or pick whatever else
you want manipulating the stock market
engaging and Corruption so vicious
people is it possible to have a world
without vicious people Marcus says no or
untrustworthy ah pistos people who you
can't rely upon even if they make
promises to you or other sorts of
commitments no people are going to act
that way not everybody right he's not
some sort of pessimist or misanthrope
but you're going to have people like
that pretty much anywhere you go and you
know people get very unrealistic about
this I'm going to go to this this school
I'm going to be in this company this
workplace I'm going to do this thing and
everything's gonna be great from now on
no Marcus would say you're being foolish
in thinking that and telling yourself
that and he tells us that we should keep
in mind or remind ourselves the word
here is actually the word for
remembering we should remind ourselves
is he says that the class the group is
going to exist right the whole class has
to exist or more literally the entire
class cannot not exist there can't not
be people of this General sort in the
world so that then that will allow us to
be more gracious more hospitable more
tolerant as a translation
right will be more peaceful more nice
more
beneficial to the the single people that
we run into so if we know that you know
the world can't exist without Shameless
people when we run into a Shameless
person we're not going to get all upset
when we run into an untrustworthy person
since we know that untrustworthy people
exist in the world we're not going to
get quite so upset with them he says
remembering that this whole class will
make you more tolerant then he says
another important point to keep in mind
and the translation here is what
qualities but it's much more literally
what virtues what Excellence is what and
it's it's done in the singular what
virtue what are
did nature provide us with towards this
particular kind of mistake
right this kind of error that people are
engaging in whether the air is
shamelessness or viciousness or
untrustworthiness or picking their nose
in public or you know uh
being cowardly or pick any other
character flaw that you want and he uses
this interesting term
anti-farmacona remedy for this
particular thing and he says that you
know here's an example the anti-farmacon
for dealing with mean or as it's
translated here
unkind people uh agnomon is gentleness
is being nice to them
the control over one's own anger not
being angry with them being patient with
them and he goes on to say every single
flaw every single Vice every single bad
characteristic that you can think of
there's an antidote for it other
qualities other virtues to balance other
flaws so you know we encounter this kind
of person well we have within us a
potentiality to behave in a certain way
to them right so for example as he's
going to say a little bit later on well
you know somebody betrayed you who the
hell told you you had to trust them
right so if somebody is untrustworthy I
mean you can still be decent to them but
don't trust them with a lot of stuff
isn't that kind of you know Common Sense
and he says you know when others stray
off course so people who are literally
wandering away from where they're
supposed to be Pepe manelon
um you know somebody who not only is
wandering away but has departed from the
path they should be on you can try to
set them straight and this means so the
the word here is
metadidascaine
is to teach and so the meta did asking
you know to to get them back onto the
proper path to show them how they should
go so he says you can always try to set
them straight every wrongdoer every
everyone who's screwing up everyone who
is airing is doing something wrong doing
something the wrong way and they don't
know that it's the wrong way or if they
they think that it is the wrong way and
they're doing it there's some other
higher level
mix-up that's happening in their head so
you can try to help them out instead he
also says another thing that will help
you not get upset with them is it seems
like they're hurting you injuring you
damaging you doing something wrong to
you and maybe they can actually like
hurt your finances you know a bad
Financial Manager who's untrustworthy
and embezzles from you they are hurting
you in some respect in relation to your
money which also might have to do with
you know your health you can't go to the
doctor or you can't enjoy certain
Pleasures but it can't really hurt the
core of who you are none of these bad
people can damage you in the real you
your mind your deanoia none of them can
make your mind worse he says unless you
in some way are going to let them and
that's that's your own damn fault he
would say right this is him talking to
himself so really they can't do you any
true harm or injury or damage he says
you know they can't do anything that
would make your mind worse that's all
that harm or injury could really mean
another really interesting uh
consideration here it comes from the
fact that we have a rational faculty
right and he says
uh boorish people do boorish things
right I mean we could pick any sort of
quality cowardly people do cowardly
things untrustworthy people betray
people's trust uh vicious people will
you know do things they're not supposed
to do Shameless people will behave
shamelessly we go on and on and on
people act the way that their character
drives them to act I mean they can make
choices to change their character but
that takes a lot of work right in in
ordinary situations if you know that
somebody is not going to get a task done
and you assign that task to them knowing
that they're the kind of person who's
going to cut corners and make excuses
that's kind of on you isn't it and
remember too Marcus is speaking to
himself as somebody who rules right so
he says that what's strange or unheard
of about people doing bad things that
are in uh you know in line with their
their character he says isn't it
yourself
that you should reproach for not
anticipating that they'd act this way
what is wrong with you dummy for
thinking that somebody who has shown
themselves a cheater wouldn't cheat on
you I'll give you a very funny example
of this I had a girlfriend when I was in
college who was an exchange student and
you know we got involved and uh she was
cheating at that time with her fiance on
her fiance with me and then she
subsequently cheated on me and I was
very surprised and angry
that was stupid from Marcus's
perspective if if she's gonna do this in
a much more momentous sort of situation
where there's an actual commitment there
why why would I expect her to be
trustworthy in that sort of case so he
goes out and he says the logos right we
have this rational capacity logos which
gave you the means to see that a given
person would act a given way but you
paid no attention that and that's a
choice that's a decision on your part
you know to expect people who have not
developed their character except in bad
ways to behave in good ways is just
silly and foolish and irrational
so he says you know when you call some
now you're astonished he's gone and done
it when you call somebody untrustworthy
or ungrateful
turn the reproach around on yourself I
mean you can complain about them if you
want but complain to yourself about
yourself you're the one who actually
screwed up
you did wrong in expecting people not to
do wrong when they're the kind of people
who characteristically do wrong he says
assuming that somebody with those traits
deserved your trust or doing somebody a
favor and expecting something in return
instead of looking to the action itself
for your reward what else did you expect
from helping somebody out
if they're not the kind of person who's
going to be gracious and show
reciprocity with other people why the
hell would they do it with you right and
he concludes this by saying you know
it's enough if we do the right thing for
the right reasons not to get some sort
of reward from people who aren't going
to provide it he says isn't it enough
you've done what your nature demands and
this is a really important phrase right
so it's enough for us to do what is in
our distinctively human nature Kata
Fusion
you are a human being
so it's not just acting in accordance
with nature katafucine it's acting in
accordance with human nature your nature
the way that a human being
ought to behave and what does this look
like for Marcus I mean he talks about
this at many places in this work but he
says
um as if your eye is expected a reward
for seeing your feet for walking that's
what they're made for right that's what
they're designed to do they have a
function
what is your function as as this thing
that includes eyes and feet but also a
rational mind he says human beings were
made to help others when we do help
others and the word for help others is
sort of cooperating with them working in
the same tasks collaborating when we
help others or help them to do something
we're doing what we were designed for
what it is that is our nature we perform
our function if we focus on what we do
rather than on what other people do
we're gonna avoid getting foolishly
upset with them when they let us down
and they actually they don't let us down
right they behave exactly the way that
we should have anticipated or expected
them to do based on their past Behavior
and the character that they're
displaying so this can be very very
helpful as a set of Rights response as a
sort of bundle of ways of looking at
things to people who are doing the wrong
thing if we do this we can avoid getting
ourselves upset angry hateful towards
them it doesn't mean that we have to
approve of their wrongdoing we can still
say that they're doing the wrong thing
but we don't have to allow it to get us
upset and demanding worlds that don't
really exist we can live in this real
world filled with people who are going
to screw up and keep ourselves from
screwing up in our responses to them and
having better responses as a replacement
for those other misguided responses on
our part